okay
[Music]
so one of my fondest memory was
um when she followed me into an allen on
meeting to play me a song
yes I
don't remember no Cheryl she cares as if
I liked it
um
so uh I have been lucky enough to know
her she's written a million songs for me
there was one that she wrote and I just
said I'm not doing it I'm not doing it
I'm not doing it and then she said I'll
pay for it and I clutched my heart and
fell to my knees because she's the
cheapest woman any of us have ever known
foreign
[Applause]
anyway I am so thrilled to present this
to you you've waited so [ __ ] long
oh my God
his show doesn't go east of the 405 for
anybody this is a big [ __ ] thing
um oh my God stay here with me I've
stage fright okay thank you um
okay
um thank you so much thank you okay
um Mom I finally found a man
[Applause]
um like like I know you wanted him to be
a nice Jewish boy but it's really hard
to tell
that I was not sure but whatever he's
still a guy I'm taking him home and
we're gonna have a very good life
together
um and I've been waiting a long [ __ ]
time for him
okay
um thank you so much okay I've been I've
waited four it's not 40 [ __ ] um I've
waited 34 years to say this
I'd like to thank the academy
thank you everybody that oh my God thank
you oh [ __ ] this is amazing so and I
finally get to say a speech because I've
had a lot of speeches that got crumpled
up in my pocket
and um so I get to say one now um so
sometimes I want to say this so
sometimes people say how does it feel to
lose 13 times
wait I say what do you mean I've won 13
times
I have
because out of the hundreds of songs and
movies every year hundreds of movies
hundreds of songs 13 times my songs were
picked to be one of only five five songs
chosen okay
and chosen not by just anybody by but
the by the greatest people in music in
the in the movie business on the planet
that's a pretty big [ __ ] win right
that being said it feels good to win I
actually have one of these things okay
um so I love writing songs and I love
writing songs for movies I remember one
of the first times feeling the power of
a song in a movie it was when I was
little and seeing Born Free with my mom
and dad did anybody see that movie when
they were little
do you remember when Elsa comes back to
show her baby lions to the couple who
saved her and that beautiful song by
John Berry and Don black Born Free is
playing
it wrecked me
it also showed me the power of a a
beautiful song in a movie
I remember watching the Oscars every
year with my mom and dad and they're up
there and they're up there watching now
and was going to try not to cry but
um I'm like sorry you guys this is
emotional for me
um an ugly crying on a big screen is not
pretty I'm sorry
but my my dad is saying to my mom see I
told you so
Talent
and now look Flora she's getting an
Oscar
see Mom
my mom is saying because she always used
to say when I play her a song
that's really a beautiful song Diane now
go to Ralph's and see if they'll give
you some groceries for it
she's she did she really did she's now
saying I'm very happy you can get
groceries with with your songs now and
that you got a man even if he's well
even well even even if he's kind of
short
um
but I know she was proud she was just
trying to protect me because really when
you think about it what were the chances
a kid from Van Nuys who knew no one in
the music or movie business would ever
succeed
my mom used to say just tell them you're
Jewish
maybe that would well that was yeah she
did say that
anyways
um I just love that I get to do this
that I get to write songs that I get to
write a song for a movie that can make
someone cry give someone hope make
someone feel something make a memorable
moment something they might remember
their whole life
this is what I was born to do this is
what I just love to do I can't believe
I'm standing here right now and that
this is really happening thank you
everyone who has helped me along my
journey some of you are here tonight
thank you so much to all you you guys
know who you are
um I wouldn't be here without you
and I'd like to say one more thing one
more time the words I thought I would
never get to say but always dreamed I
would I'd like to thank the academy
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]